[Music]
hola mi Gente welcome back to another
video today's video is actually really
fun I wanted to step up my gift wrapping
game this year in particular so I looked
up a whole bunch of gift wrapping ideas
and just like I went shopping for
ribbons and like strings which I've
never done before all these gifts were
actually from Macy's so thank you to
Macy's for sponsoring today's video now
I am such a fan of actually gift
wrapping all these years I'm always like
hiding in the closet or like just trying
to wrap one gift at a time because I
don't want Casey or Isaac or anyone else
to see every year I'm always just like
oh you know what just the most basic rap
with no accessories on the gift or
anything when you wrap a gift for me
personally it's like you're putting your
effort into wrapping a gift you're
really putting your thought your love
for me personally I've always wanted to
learn how to do some fancier techniques
or like some actual like actually no
know how to do a bow out of a ribbon and
all that stuff now this year I made it a
point I'm like you know what I'm gonna
learn how to do this and I'm gonna do it
for you guys to see as well to maybe
give you guys some ideas that you can
use for your gift wrapping this year and
maybe you know you can impress some
people with your skills that you might
pick up from this video hopefully I
don't know we'll see all right now let's
see what's under this gift wrapping
all right so before we begin I want to
talk about Macy's because I got all
these gifts from Macy's it is a go-to
gift destination if you're looking for
inspiration selection or value Macy's
got your back just like how they got my
back I got most of my Christmas shopping
done already thanks to Macy's so it's
really cool the way I actually got most
of my shopping done was through their
gift finder so you can easily look for
items based on category interest or
price for example they have gifts under
25 or 50 or a hundred dollars or you can
look into you know for example a teen
boy which is exactly what I picked to
select Isaac's things and it's really
cool because Macy's has a wide selection
of Brands and designers at a really
great price so for example this year for
the holidays I decided to treat myself
and get the instapot duo crisp and air
fryer this baby is 11 and in one product
I saw it on Macy's gift finder and I'm
like oh my gosh immediately has to go in
my cart along with all these other gifts
that I was able to get for our immediate
family and for Casey's family as well so
anyway the instapot is so amazing you
can air fry bake roast broil dehydrate
saute steam sous-vide keep warm slow
cooked pressure cooked you could do
everything with this daily I'm gonna get
rid of so many appliances in my kitchen
thanks to this new instapot I am so
happy I found it at Macy's and I got it
for under a hundred and fifty dollars
Macy's often puts this on sale so make
sure to check out their website super
excited because this is the one gift I
got for myself before we begin make sure
to check out Macy's for all your holiday
needs you can shop in store or online at
macys.com gift finder and they make it
super easy to get your gifts with
curbside pickup pickup in store or same
day delivery with some items now for our
first gift is this Nautica portable
charger I am gifting this to Isaac so
you know he's a team boy constantly on
this phone constantly having a dead
phone because he's always on his phone
so he's not charging it very well
especially when we're on the go he's
like Mom do you have a charger with you
do you have a charger with you so here
you go you don't have to worry about it
Mason's got my back because I actually
found this under the team section now
this wrapping technique is incredibly
ambitious just as a reminder all these
wrapping techniques that I'm going to be
trying throughout this entire video I
have never tried before so if it's a
complete and utter fail now you know why
I've never tried it so this is my first
attempt hopefully they come out great
the fact that I'm actually relying on
the fact that I'm such a perfectionist
so hopefully that comes through tonight
all right here we go
[Music]
foreign
all right ribbon time
[Music]
yeah I like it
I think I did pretty good I'm really
proud I'm I'm very very hopeful for the
rest of these gifts did you start off
with the hardest one
there's harder ones all right now for
the next gift is also for Isaac so I
have a champion shirt and Champion
shorts here so this is more for like
lounging around at home Isaac recently
started getting into fitness so it's
perfect for that
[Music]
[Music]
thank you foreign
[Music]
okay next one is a gift for Luca so this
is a magnetic wood stacker rocket so
Luca's whole theme in his room is space
because when he was a baby in the
ultrasound photo Casey said they look
like a little astronaut because before
we had we knew that we were having a boy
so anyway we've stuck with the whole
Space theme I found this on Macy's gift
guide for babies and I just thought this
is perfect he's at the perfect age
no it says 12 months and up
um so he will be the perfect date
he will get this for Christmas but in
one month he'll be turning a year so
it's a perfect date just fine anyway
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
I'm sure Luca will appreciate this gift
wrapping I know right
[Music]
so it's supposed to be a little bit more
fanned out like more from like edge to
edge but it'll do
that'll do pig that'll do all right up
next we have the Skip Hop four in one
grow along activity Walker for Luca so
it's pretty cool because it can he can
use this when he sits for cruising as a
shopping cart and as a stroller how
freaking cute is that I actually didn't
even notice these two until I just read
it to you right now currently he's nine
months and he just started like pushing
himself up and standing on his own so
I'm like any day now he's gonna start
walking so I know this would be kind of
a cool thing for him to like push and
like stabilize with
[Music]
thank you
I severely underestimated how much
wrapping paper I needed for this
I'm missing from here to here but I do
have this spare
that's gonna work okay that works
[Music]
yeah I'm trying to do a bow
with wire ribbon never done this before
so we'll see how this turns out
[Applause]
I like this one four down five to go
wait yes yeah is that the mat one two
three four five yeah that's the last all
right next up is this two-in-one smart
mug warmer and Qi wireless charger this
gift is actually for Casey yep so he's
filming so there we go you know what
you're getting this is my first time
watching someone gift wrap my present
really I don't think I don't think I've
ever seen anyone gift wrapped the
present that they were giving me yeah
that's true
I would wrap my own presents as a child
so I would watch myself that's sad so
this is really cool it actually keeps
mug warm and keeps his phone charged so
the reason why I selected this gift in
particular for him is because Casey's
always making his teas he used to be a
coffee drinker but ever since like a few
years ago now he's been a tea drinker
exclusively and so he creates his own
teas and then he ends up getting sucked
into editing or working or with Luca or
some something and his drink is always
cold and so he's always saying like oh
man this drink is cold so I'm like oh
mug warmer for him and I just love you
so much
I love you too baby but not just that he
always has his phone dead too all the
time so while he's sipping his drink he
can place his phone to charge and then
he can uh also not have a phone battery
that's like on two percent all the time
so you take it off and becomes a phone
charger that's so cool yeah okay does it
burn the phone
foreign
[Music]
this was a pain in the butt
I got it should I add ribbon I gotta use
all this ribbon I bought
[Music]
okay now we're done all right up next
here also for Casey is the Magic Bullet
mini juicer so Casey's been really into
juicing lately he's been trying like to
juice different fruits and he's been
wanting a juicer I got him one of the
handheld ones but it's a lot of work and
it's just not the same so I was looking
for a juicer specifically one that would
be small so our house is Tiny and I
didn't want like a full-size juicer
because we don't have any room for a
full-size Appliance but I found this one
and at a really good price too so check
it out
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
and this little pocket that I made
that's sick all these other wrapping
techniques I've been following other
people
other people's videos as they're doing
it
this is my own creation
Regional
it's probably not original it's probably
copied from something I watched I've
been watching a ton of gift wrapping
videos all right on to the next one
all right up next is this wooden cheese
board with this beautiful ocean kind of
design here so this will be gifted to
Carrie and Diana so Carrie is Casey's
brother and Diana's his wife and I was
really trying to find gifts because I
Oh wait we're spending Christmas over
there
honey because I was about to say that I
was trying to find gifts that would be
easily like placed in their suitcase I
guess it would be placed in our suitcase
anyway the point is because either we
travel or they travel for Christmas so
Christmas gifts for them and for Casey's
parents in my mind always have to be
like small compact like they can put in
their suitcase or we put it in our
suitcase anyway point is this is uh
their gift so I'm gonna be wrapping this
next
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
it's nice very good
can you go very nice all right up next
is this mini percussion muscle massager
and this is for Casey's parents so mama
and papa Chan I picked this particular
gift for them because they've been
traveling so much so lots of time spent
in the airplane lots of time spent on
the road during their road trips so I'm
sure you know their muscles get tense so
this could be a nice little like you
know to loosen up their muscles while
they're being sedentary for such a long
time during their travels and it's also
tiny for us to like take to them or for
them to take from here whatever it's a
small gift
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
so it didn't come out exactly how it
should have been which is all these
points meeting in the middle but we did
what we could and I still like how it
came out so it's fine last but not least
is the insta pot that I purchased for
myself it's really for the family
because they're going to be the ones
reaping the benefits of this instapot
you know but anyway this is the final
one and like I mentioned earlier I was
so excited when I found this on Macy's
gift guide because I'm like oh my
goodness there's also a sale on it too
so
super happy about it now let's wrap this
baby and finish this video up
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
last one is all done I was really tired
rapping so all I did was a fancy bow
all right here are all the gifts nice
and wrapped hopefully you guys were able
to get some new ideas for how to wrap
your gifts for this holiday season
honestly my personal favorite one has to
be the one that I read for Casey I
really like this one even though it's
like not that special but like I don't
know I usually like the strings also
this one for Isaac I really like that
one a lot but yeah I don't know I had so
much fun doing this even though it took
forever but I feel like it was well
worth it well worth the effort now my
most favorite thing that I'm really
looking forward to is to see everyone
open their gifts and hopefully they love
it even though I spent so much time and
effort like wrapping everything I
personally love when people just attack
it like attack the gift wrapping we're
just like oh my gosh let me see what's
in there so that's the kind of
unwrapping I'm looking forward to seeing
on Christmas or it might be Thanksgiving
because everyone's coming over here for
Thanksgiving we're gonna go to Dallas
for Christmas I don't know we'll see
what happens but anyway once again thank
you to Macy's for sponsoring today's
video make sure to check out their gift
guide highly recommend shopping at
Macy's for all your holiday Beats see
you guys next time bye
[Music]
foreign